you shouldn't be banned from one
platform and not others if you are for
providing misinformation out there
hello humanoids and other assorted
creatures I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report it is July the 6th 2023 we
are live streaming on Rumble locals and
YouTube Share subscribe tap the
notification Bell if you have not if you
want to join us for the post game show
to ask me questions to offer up
commentary to critique and make me think
you can do that at
reubenreport.locals.com and that cold
open that clownish buffoonish Jen saki
uh is a good segue to what we're going
to be doing on the show today because as
you know the big news of the last couple
days has been the Supreme Court
decisions they've been laying out some
big stuff some major decisions and the
left and the Democrats and the
mainstream media and the corporate press
and that whole Cadre of clown car crazy
people they ain't happy about it and
right now what we are seeing is
virtually all of them all of them openly
and quite literally disregard the rule
of law checks and balances and the Very
Constitution itself and part of that is
because some of these decisions have
really kneecapped Joe Biden's agenda and
they ain't happy about that so we're
going to do a couple things do we have
to warn you in advance we have a couple
clips of AOC she is completely bananas
so you are warned and then after all
that we've got a Reuben report Community
Q a uh let's get right to it why not
right I mean uh what else do we have to
do today do a show as long as we're
sitting here we'll do a show so of
course the big the big three uh
decisions that the Supreme Court laid
out were the affirmative action decision
you guys know all about that that
affirmative action will no longer be
allowed to be used as part of college
admissions which is fantastic we are
removing systemic racism from the system
itself you don't want to judge people by
the color of their skin but by the
content of their character there was
some old guy who used to say something
like that the other one that the Supreme
Court ruled against uh was student debt
forgiveness loan forgiveness and of
course this was a major promise that Joe
Biden made right before the election
everybody knew it was unconstitutional
the government has no right to just wipe
away anyone's debt I've got a mortgage
I'd like them to wipe away my debt the
government cannot just do that but Biden
who had previously said it was illegal
to do Nancy Pelosi who was speaker of
the house at the time she had previously
said it was illegal to do they said they
were going to do it knowing it was going
to get young people to vote for them
young people did vote for them voted
more so for Democrats than most people
thought in the midterms the Red Wave
never happened and then of course it
gets struck down by the Supreme Court so
they're not happy about affirmative
action they're not happy about that and
then of course the third one was this
Colorado web designer who was granted
the right not to service those who go
against his faith meaning if he didn't
want to do a website for gay porn for
example he doesn't have to be forced
into doing that he has to offer the same
services to everyone regardless of a
mutable characteristics right we have
the anti-discrimination laws of the
early 60s but you obviously wouldn't
want to force a Jewish pain painter to
have to paint Jews in gas Chambers you
wouldn't force a let's say Muslim Baker
to bake a cake with the image of their
Prophet Muhammad on it
etc etc so these things all of these
decisions put choice and individual
rights back in the hands of the people
they were they were all good and as you
guys know when good things happen that
freaks out the progressives here is uh
noted wizard Alexandria
ocasio-cortez on CNA on CNN
aoccnn basically saying that the Supreme
Court must be destroyed
congresswoman you've called on President
Biden to expand the Supreme Court to 13
justices but even after uh Roe was
overruled last year and this past week
what we saw with affirmative action and
other cases I want you to listen to what
President Biden said that he just said
this on Thursday on MSNBC
I think if we start the process of
trying to expand the court
we're going to pull through the size of
maybe forever in a way that is not
healthy that you can't get back you
can't get back
I'd like you to respond to that and also
you mentioned a moment ago judicial
review are you also saying that the
justices power should somehow be limited
I I truly do and this is not a new
um this is not a new development in
history this is part of our system of
checks and balances the courts if they
were to proceed without any check on
their power without any balance on their
power then we will start to see an
undemocratic and frankly dangerous
authoritarian expansion of power in the
Supreme Court which is what we are
seeing now AOC is truly like it's one of
these things like the road to hell is
paid with good intentions so let's for
one second because I'm not going to do
it for more than about two seconds uh
let's say she has good intentions you
guys all know where good intentions take
us right the road to hell it's paved by
them but I actually don't think she has
good intentions I think she would love
to undo everything that is good about
the United States I don't think she just
doesn't understand the issues I think
she is actively pursuing a series of
policies that would undermine the
Constitution the checks and balances
that she's pretending to care about and
when she dare say she's worried about
authoritarianism is there anything she
wouldn't want the power to tell you to
do so just very quickly I was bulleting
bulleting it out while she was talking
there first off we should not have an
expansion of the court right the court
is now made up of justices who have all
been uh nominated by presidents and then
brought in by the Congress right and
Senate they were all allowed into the
court and that's how it works that's
just how it works the idea you know then
they talk about Roe for just as that is
a lot here really this morning I got a
guy downstairs doing electric work at
the Haywire day uh
the row situation did not take away
anyone's rights as you guys know right
what did the Roe v Wade decision the
reversal of Roe v Wade do it just said
hey there's no constitutional right to
abortion it's just not in the
Constitution itself we looked at the doc
and uh no the word abortion's not in
here it's not here so when things are
not in this document this Constitution
which by the way she doesn't like very
much but when they're not in here that
means the power goes back to the state
so all they did was abide by the
Constitution that that is regardless of
your personal feelings about abortion
right so okay that's one thing and then
this idea that the Justice's power is
not limited lady the justices have to be
nominated by the president they have to
be confirmed by the Senate that is how
their power is limited in the first
place right there's a process to put
them there and the Constitution limits
their power by default meaning we have
three branches of government I know
she's not very good at this we have the
legislative branch right that is
Congress and the Senate they write law
laws the president what does he do he's
in charge of the executive branch he
signs those laws into law they put a
bill at his decides the bill into law
they put it at his desk he signs it
right he's got a lot of pens and then of
course the legisl uh the uh judicial
branch sorry the judicial branch which
then says oh are these things legal do
they abide by the laws of the land the
Constitution the Bill of Rights etc etc
and what the court decided in these
three decisions was we should not
discriminate based on skin color that's
good right they said we should not force
anyone to use their artistic uh talents
in a way that they do not want that's
good and that if you take debt on you
it's not for someone else to pay off so
when she's pretending that these things
are the are the courts legislating or
the courts overstepping their bounds
it's the complete reverse so it is up to
you to decide whether you think she's
just willfully ignorant or dangerously
malicious obviously I think it's the
latter and if you want proof that it's
the latter she wants Congress to
actually investigate Chief Justice John
Roberts and Clarence Thomas
we have members of the Court themselves
with Justice Elena Kagan saying that the
court is beginning to assume the power
of a legislature and right now whether
it is expansion of the court I'm sorry
to interrupt but I just want to how do
you do that how do you are you proposing
a law
or Bill I I there's several ways first
we have a Senate Judiciary Committee
that is beginning the process of
investigating the entanglements and
conflicts of interest I believe that if
Justice if chief justice Roberts will
not come before Congress for an
investigation voluntarily I believe that
we should be considering subpoenas we
should be considering investigations we
must pass much more binding and
stringent ethics guidelines where we see
members of Congress where we see members
of the of the Supreme Court potentially
breaking the law as we saw in the
refusal you know with Clarence Thomas to
recuse himself from cases implicating
his wife in in January 6th there also
must be impeachment on the table
impeachment investigations take out
everyone on that court that I don't like
and somehow they're the authoritarians
she would love if she could give
Clarence Thomas the boot and John
Roberts and everyone who wasn't a far
left Progressive on that court she would
love to pack the court so her
legislative agenda would never be
challenged she's the authoritarian right
she's the authoritarian by the way
speaking of the Supreme Court did we
ever find out who leaked uh the Roe v
Wade decision remember that isn't that
bizarre we never found that out it
happened a month before the decision
came out it's also kind of bizarre you
know they found a whole bunch of cocaine
at the white house the other day Hunter
Biden happened to be there the same day
CNN and political reported yesterday
investigators are saying we're never
going to know who brought it in God the
machine you have to admire it it's evil
at some points but one more from AOC
because Clarence Thomas really went
after katanji Brown Jackson uh in one of
his uh briefings and I thought it was
quite you'll see well he's giving you
Thomas soul level stuff here and uh AOC
ain't having it here is part of what
Justice Thomas wrote he said quote
Justice Jackson uses her broad
observations about statistical
relationships between race and select
measures of health wealth and well-being
to label all blacks as victims her
desire to do so is unfathomable to me it
is an insult to individual achievement
and cancerous to Young Minds seeking to
push through barriers their race is not
to blame for everything good or bad that
happens in their lives what is your
response to that
I mean what's Justice Clarence Thomas
wrote there I believe is profoundly
disrespectful
um to to I just think it was profoundly
disrespectful to his colleague it
includes sweeping uh assumptions about
her worldview whereas when you look at
what
um what the response was from Justice
katanji Brown we saw that her descent
was grounded in fact it was grounded in
the facts of the case for him to come
out and insinuate that her opinion is
due to
some sort of
inferior or less than uh you know less
than than
really thought out of a stance I think
it's profoundly insulting you're
profoundly insulting you brain dead
Dullard what Thomas said very clearly in
in all of his remarks right because they
have they have to write basically essays
explaining their decisions right and
they're also allowed to write about the
dissenters and the dissenters are
allowed to write about the people who
are on the other side of it that's how
that's how the whole thing works if you
think for one second that Clarence
Thomas wasn't thought out when he was
criticizing katanji Brown Jackson
katanji Brown Jackson is doing
Progressive 101 right that skin color
matters more than anything else that we
should destroy meritocracy in the name
of collectivism that we should pick
winners and losers etc etc so he's not
he's not going after her in a way that
is unjust what AOC does not like is that
katanji brown Jackson and AOC are on the
wrong side of this thing and most people
know it right I mean I get that there is
like this hysterical never-ending
screeching AOC style mainstream media
person who demands that we look at
everyone's race and is obsessed with
everyone's genitals and everything else
but the average person when that court
order came down last week I really think
the average person was just looked at it
for anyone who's just paying attention
you know not the most hyper political
people the average person was like yeah
we shouldn't be discriminating and we
should stop punishing Asian kids and we
should stop punishing white kids and if
there were any laws that were stopping
Black
kids from getting into schools then sure
we should look at that we should not
have any discrimination but you have to
understand these people are upset that
people are allowed to make choices like
the the issue with the web designer in
Colorado they are upset that people who
make bad choices say getting a whole
bunch of student loans to go to Syracuse
to get a useless degree in
Communications uh have to pay the price
for that and they are upset that
discrimination will not be part of the
college admissions admissions process
this is the backwards way they look at
everything but of course then there are
luminaries wise elderly Statesmen that
we have like Joe Biden the elderly man
pretending to be president and he was
asked what he thought about these
Supreme Court decisions with all his
incredible wisdom take a look are you
did you overstep your Authority I think
the court misinterpreted the
Constitution
I get it he's mind muddled and whatever
he knows they didn't misinterpret the
Constitution where in the constitution
does it say if you take out loans that
the government should be able to wipe
away those loans where in the
constitution does it say that schools
should be allowed to discriminate
against people that would be against the
Constitution because we have individual
rights you get it with the with the
Colorado website designer where it is in
the Constitution to say you should force
people to use their artistic skills in a
way that you wish that they could it's
everything they say is nonsense that's
why it's never detailed it's never
nuanced right it's these broad sweeping
statements show me I'm trying here to
give you like the specifics well what is
in the Constitution individual rights
are in the Constitution right free
speech is in the Constitution for
example the right to bear arms the right
to peaceably assemble etc etc there are
things that are specifically in there
but they take things that are not in
there abortion and then if you kick it
back to the states which is in the
Constitution if it's not in the
Constitution you let you leave it up to
the states not up to the federal
government these are all see the problem
also is that they don't care about any
of these things like we can all talk
about how the thing is supposed to work
we can talk about what's in the
Constitution we can talk about what's in
the Bill of Rights and all those things
but the more that it goes against their
agenda to them that's more fuel to the
fire to burn down these documents and
all of our institutions in the first
place uh but some other things have
happened over the last couple days that
are also kneecapping Joe Biden's
authoritarian to use aoc's word uh
agenda uh here is a federal judge now
has issued an order that the executive
agencies the CIA FBI et cetera et cetera
they are no longer allowed to collude
with big tech companies to censor you I
thought that was sort of baked into the
whole freaking thing already but we know
over the last couple years it's not
here's a little more on that federal
judge says the Biden Administration may
have violated the First Amendment during
the pandemic by censoring social media
posts Justice correspondent David spun
reports live from the D.C Newsroom David
what can you tell us hi Jillian this is
a temporary injunction not a final
ruling however this temporary injunction
could have major implications on Free
Speech it came down today on a Federal
holiday from a federal judge in
Louisiana Judge Terry Dottie blocked
officials and agencies in the Biden
Administration from communicating with
social media companies think Facebook
Google Twitter about the topic of
protected speech okay so before we get
to what they've done in the past what
this judge just did with this temporary
injection is fantastic right we know
that the CIA the FBI the intelligence
agencies that they were working with
tech companies we know that I've showed
you a billion clips of all of that right
Jen sake we flag posts for Facebook at
the height of kovid we now know through
the Twitter files that there were eight
government agents literally working at
Twitter some of them may still work
there now so God only knows how many of
them work at Facebook and YouTube and
everything else once a government agent
is doing something with a big Tech
organization uh to censor you or to
imply censorship there were also emails
leaked where government agents were
basically saying we know this from Mark
Zuckerberg on Joe Biden we've on Joe
Biden on Joe Rogan we've shown you that
clip uh where Zuckerberg said you know a
little bit before the hunter Biden story
broke we got word from the government
that something was coming and we should
just cool it so we did what we could
right so they have absolutely infringed
on My First Amendment right to free
speech and your First Amendment right to
free speech let's not forget in July
2021 when I said that mandates were
coming and the vaxes weren't working I
was banned from Twitter right I was
banned from Twitter thankfully I have
local so I was still able to get word
out and then eventually enough people
caught wind of it and they brought me
back Jordan Peterson banned from Twitter
for saying that uh Ellen Page is a male
and Ellen Page is a male okay that's
just the truth you can chop body parts
off it doesn't change your biology the
question is if the government
was working with people to silence any
of us then it is a violation of the
First Amendment now I've talked about
this before and I've talked to several
uh First Amendment lawyers on this it's
a really interesting thing it turns out
that you actually don't have uh many uh
options to when the government does
violate your first amendment so meaning
let's say we found out for sure without
question that the government when I was
banned from Twitter they didn't want it
out known that the boxes weren't working
which is what I said they weren't
working as promised they also had
mandates coming they didn't want that
out if someone from the government
called Twitter or emailed someone at
Twitter and said hey take this post down
you would think that I have some
recourse with the government but you
really don't you really don't I've
talked about this with Harmony Dylan and
many other lawyers like you can maybe
get involved in a lawsuit and spend a
whole bunch of money and maybe the
government will issue an apology but
there's no punitive damages on that
they're not going to write a check
here's 10 million sorry about that
violation of your first amendment so
that's why they keep doing it also no
one ever gets fired from the tech
company please nobody ever gets fired
for the government etc etc
here is White House spokeswoman or man
whatever she is cringe Jean-Pierre and
she disagrees and believes that the
government should be working with big
tech companies to censor you
um
there go specifically do you disagree
with the judges for them that this
coordination was the form of censorship
and specifically targeted conservative
speech look we just disagree with the
decision I'll leave it there and I'm
going to let doj do that move forward
with their evaluating process
before we get to cringe Jean-Pierre
Connor just noted I think I said did I
say that Ellen Page was a male look the
point is nobody nobody cares it's so
stupid that that even saying any of this
stuff is just ridiculous with the
pronouns and everything else but yes so
there you go so cringe jump here what is
what does she want she wants the
government to be able to censor you on
big Tech so now let's swing over to the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC here is a guy named Ryan Reilly
never heard of him before but he's I
guess a contributor over there and he's
very upset that uh the Biden
Administration is not going to be able
to censor you as much as they once could
safe to say the administration will
eventually appeal this I think that's
pretty safe and I think that that's
where the worry is in terms of
communicating uh with social media
companies about ongoing threats in the
national security threat he creates sort
of a carve out for that but essentially
what a lot of these allegations have to
do with is the government flagging posts
that violate the standards that these
social media companies have
independently set up so if they find
something that you know they're flagging
this post and say hey this they're not
explicitly saying you need to take this
down often they're sort of an implicit
uh implication there if saying oh just
you know bringing this to your attention
and then the social media company can
decide independently whether or not that
violates their ongoing standards but I
mean it's a really new area and a really
complicated one and one that there
should be close guard rails on to make
sure that the government is not
overreaching but the idea that the
government can't have any uh
communication with these social media
companies I don't think it's something
as a really a world that we would want
to live in what an absolute tool dude I
don't want to live in the world that you
want to live and you want to live in a
sensorious world what he's saying there
is the mafia move is okay first off what
right is it let's say there was all
sorts of misinformation on every social
media platform right now and guess what
there is right people lie all day long
they now with AI images and there's
going to be AI video and voice and all
of the stuff and memes and and just
everything it's it all exists right now
do you think the government should be
coming in and silencing people for that
will that make anything better of course
the answer is no but then when he says
this thing well you know they didn't
really Force anyone to do anything they
just contacted these guys just to tell
people oh you know Facebook uh some of
these people are doing things that are
against your own policies over there
I've always described this as this is
the ultimate Mafia move what does the
mafia do what does the mafia do when
they want to extract a price right they
walk into your restaurant and they go
boy this is an awfully nice restaurant
you got here it'd be a shame if
something happens to it so they didn't
just walk in and shoot you dead but they
told you you are going to behave the way
we wish that you would behave otherwise
something might happen to your
restaurant or something might happen to
your big tech company the fact that this
guy and these ideas are put on
mainstream media to to put the Nugget
into some NPC who watches MSNBC or any
of these channels to put it in their
head that oh yes well I guess I wouldn't
want to live in a world where I couldn't
be censored by the government big Tech
who what am I what am I some sort of
thinking automaton come on
anyway it just absolutely never stops
you guys know it never stops I want to
show you just like a perfect example
you know one of Michael malice's great
lines that I quote often on Twitter is
that the corporate press is the enemy of
the people right I say it I say it often
on the show and I really believe I've
really come to believe that that is true
almost everything that comes out of the
corporate press is a lie or an
obfuscation or a confusion of the truth
and every now and again a headline comes
through that it's just a perfect perfect
example of that I saw this yesterday
from CBS look at this a controversial
Florida law that took effect Saturday no
longer recognizes driver's license
issued to undocumented immigrants from
other States among other restrictions
Connor just leave that up for just a
moment now look at the way they first
off this is CBS News this is not opinion
this is not the editorial page or
anything else but look at the way they
frame it it's controversial first right
so the second word you get there uh
controversial oh well something must be
weirder than Florida controversy Florida
okay must be that right wing crazy Ron
DeSantis guy it took effect Saturday
that's fine no longer recognizes
driver's license issued to undocumented
immigrants well that's also an
interesting editorialization of what's
going on here they're not undocumented
immigrants they are illegal immigrants
right illegal immigrants from other
States among other restrictions it does
seem odd that you would have uh driver's
licenses and other pieces of identity
education for people who are here are
here illegally already but this is what
they do then the average person watches
that and they go my God it is
controversial what Florida is doing
Florida must be racist or something
but these people they watch these things
and then they become crazy they become
crazy people and to prove how crazy
these people have become one more from
MSNBC I apologize in advance it's noted
racist Joy read and thankfully if you
live near Joy read I don't know where
she lives I guess they shoot that in New
York right they shoot that thing in New
York they should probably live somewhere
in the tri-state area if you were out
and about celebrating on July 4th
fireworks hot dogs hamburgers beer the
whole thing music
you had no chance of seeing Joy Reid
because she stayed home during July 4th
because she's scared Hallelujah take a
look
Caroline light who literally wrote the
book on these laws writes for the Tampa
Bay Times that Florida has become the
stand your ground hellscape in which
lethal violence can be shoehorned into a
tidy Narrative of armed Good Guys
deflecting a multitude of suspicious bad
guys never mind that those presumed bad
guys often turn out to be pool cleaners
ride sharing customers furniture
delivery people and sometimes neighbors
um I have to say I did not go out on
July 4th and would not the idea of going
to a mass Gathering a parade or a big
fireworks thing outside seems insane to
me to be blunt in America because
America is Awash with guns and now
people don't just have them they seem to
want to shoot people with them and use
them for whatever you know yeah where
are they just using guns forever uh
we're guessing by the backdrop there
that she's actually in DC not New York
city so in DC you know there is a good
chance you'd be shot uh this craziness
where she Associates everything with
Florida and guns and everything we did a
little research Brad Brock open up the
old laptop we did a little research
Fourth of July weekend interestingly in
Chicago this was even for Chicago this
is pretty good 73 people were shot in
Chicago 11 fatal interesting you don't
know any of their names there are no
parades for any of those people or
anything because virtually all of them
were black shot by black people so that
doesn't fit the narrative can't do that
how many so that's Chicago which has
basically the strictest gun laws in the
entire uh country Chicago of course is a
city in a state of Illinois how many
people were shot in Florida 14 in the
entire State uh one was fatal do you see
the difference there do you see the
absolute difference these people lie and
then and then you have this crazy
psychotic lunatic and that's the only
way I can describe her Joy Reid who is
afraid of going out because of gun
violence
it is truly truly wild I've got one more
for you because I've given you a lot of
crazy right we plowed through AOC and
MSNBC clips and Joy Reid I've been
bludgeoning you God bless you for
watching the program today as I've
abused you slapped you across your
virtual face how about a little sanity
how about a little does sanity how do we
fix this thing well we got to stand up
for what's right it ain't that
complicated
this has gone on across this country for
far too long 2024
is the time to put up or shut up no more
excuses about why we can't win against
the left no more excuses about why you
didn't do what you said you would do the
time to act is now and I believe if we
do it right
2024 is going to be the year when the
parents across this country finally
fight back
[Applause]
yeah I mean you know I don't have to
belabor the point you know I think he's
right if we all just start acting
seriously if we start voting in the
right people if we mock the other people
to Oblivion if we expose them for what
they are if we stop giving them power
and attention and money and votes we
could fix the freaking thing
and we shall have peace all right people
let's get to a Reuben report locals
Community Q a here we go it always says
for most of my life before becoming
quote right wing I thought of the
concept uh I thought the concept of
normal was an impossible goal as
everyone is different with the calls now
going out for a return to normal is that
an even achievable goal and what does it
even mean to you wow that was a helpless
hell of a segue from from the normalcy I
just threw you uh yes I do think normal
so okay so what is what does normal mean
um we all probably have some different
Divergent view of normal but a basic
understanding that we have rule of law
you can't break the law you can't just
walk into a CVS and steal a whole bunch
of stuff you can't smoke crack on the
street basic reality boys are boys and
girls are girls racism is not cool like
we can get back to something which again
I always describe as this was the
childhood that I had in the 80s it
worked through the 90s and and into much
of the 2000s we had solved most of these
problems we had put this stuff to bed it
doesn't mean it was perfect but it was
roughly normal we had some things that
brought us together sports for example
NFL NBA MLB NHL they weren't overly
politicized so you could watch say the
Super Bowl with your family and you
didn't have to worry that there was
going to be some crazy messaging about
some woke nonsense or you could watch
the Oscars 20 years ago where they were
always a little bit political but it
wasn't it wasn't sheer lunacy something
normal would be something cultural that
we'd all be like yeah you know there's
some weird stuff and we can agree to
disagree but we're basically back to
something saying to me at a political
level I think DeSantis is the guy that
can shift us back there it's not all
political right it starts with you first
it starts with The Mamas at the school
boards and all of those things but
politically I think I think the piece of
it that you need at the executive level
at the presidency DeSantis obviously is
the right guy on that Caesar says what's
your next car something cool or a boring
mini minivan so you know we have only
had one car for years forever the two of
us have only had one car we are we had
for many years we had a Chevy Equinox
which I absolutely loved and then about
uh it was about probably five years ago
we shipped over to the to the Tesla
Model X which is absolutely awesome
obviously it's not cheap but it is just
such a incredible beautiful piece of
technology and machinery and everything
about it is just absolutely wonderful
um finally now with the two kids uh we
did we got a second one so we got a
second model X the exact same car one's
in white one's in black but it's the
same exact car because having two kids
uh knowing that like you just need you
need two cars you need the ability if
there was an emergency you got to get
somewhere you got to get to the doctor
or whatever we were just like all right
we got to get two cars and we thought
about a whole bunch of different cars we
were going to go with the SUV just in
terms of room and space and you know
kids in the back of that whole thing we
thought of a whole bunch and then it was
just like yes this thing is not cheap
but there's just nothing better there
just is nothing better if you have not
been in a in any of the Teslas and even
if you can't afford it go go to your
local mall go to the Tesla shop that's
in your mall or go to your you know
local Tesla outlet and just sit in one
or take a ride and when it's so cool the
technology is so cool the touch screen
uh you know there's no traditional
engine so it's smooth the audio system's
great but it's really it's something
else uh FB says have you seen Anna
kasparian's Awakening about how off the
rails the left has gone I hope you can
reach out to her and guide your former
co-worker as she starts the same Journey
you have already gone on we need to
embrace people who want to come to the
side of Truth uh you know I don't know
much about this but I will
say this you know in all my so for those
of you that don't know Anna is the uh
the co-host of The Young Turks Network
that was the network that I was on for a
couple years before my own political
Awakening and going independent and
everything that you now uh know me for
Anna and I were Incredibly Close she was
really like a sister to me and she was
at our place every weekend and
barbecuing and having drinks and going
out and hanging out she was invited to
our wedding which was about eight months
after we left The Young Turks I never
had a problem with her I thought we were
still friends when we left look
you know I don't do the internet drama
thing it's not my thing she has said
unbelievably dishonest like crazy crazy
things about me the The Young Turks
themselves are just like I never go
after them do I I don't know if I've
even mentioned them on this show in five
seven years I have literally no idea
um but they go after me all the time it
doesn't even matter if she's waking up
if she's breaking out of the progressive
group think uh which I've seen a few
people on Twitter saying that sort of
thing because they tag me on it that's
great and there's really nothing I have
to do because once you start seeing the
truth you'll either go to the truth or
you'll just run back the other way I
suspect like it's sort of like you know
you can't put a wave back in a cup and
if it's happening it'll happen for her
um and I hope it happens for her and I
think she would probably find out the
things that I found out which are that
these crazy right Wingers these Ben
Shapiro's and Dennis pragers and Glenn
Becks and Dave rubins and Larry Elders
and Jordan Peterson's they're not so bad
and they just want to Live and Let Live
and we can agree to disagree and the
rest of it so if she's on that path I
wish her the best and hopefully uh
yeah well I'd leave it at that uh Bonnie
says Joe Rogan went on a bit of a rant
Tuesday about how in general Republicans
are anti-gay this is a stigma the left
has done a great job repeating over and
over for years and they have no problem
looking into a camera and straight up
lying I feel about Joe Rogan as you do
about Bill Maher he gets so many things
right and then he just fails on this BS
how do we fight this stigma we're not
anti-gay or transphobic just stop trying
to sexualize children it's so
frustrating look this is one of the ones
where I think that last little step for
a lot of the the red pilled people the
Bill Maher types the rogans as you
mentioned these types of people they get
hung up on a couple things like they get
hung up on something related to gays
which I think my life is an example that
it just simply is not true it just is
not true generally people on the right
are more religious right so they do have
their own religious beliefs but for the
most part they've stopped trying to
legislate those religious beliefs and
that's what this the damn shame of what
this LGBT activist
hegemonic lunacy has done because once
people got equality you could have just
taken your foot off the pedal a little
bit been like oh we got a quality it's
good but then it morphed into this crazy
tea thing and all the stuff about the
kids and then it gets people on the
right knowing uh justifiably upset right
it gets it gets me upset right as a
parent it gets me upset so they've done
something very dangerous there I think
Rogan probably is just oh it's he's
probably just a little bit confused
about what the truth is on that I'd be
happy to have that uh conversation with
him I actually I just sent him a note
before the show because I did see this
question I think that would be a great
thing to talk about it's like why am I
welcome to the dinner table with Glenn
Beck and Larry Elder and Jordan and all
of these people right they can see
things a little bit differently but do
you think they don't want Douglas Murray
as part of their movement Douglas who
happens to be gay do you think they
don't want Peter Thiel to be part of
their movement or or a functional member
of society of course not of course not
and and Trump to his credit did an
incredibly good job by basically saying
it's not an issue it's not an issue for
me and then he got this broad diverse
diverse in the right sense uh Coalition
of people to help him get elected in
2016.
um I think that there is a fundamental
difference between the G's and the L's
and the B's and what's going on with the
T thing and I think more and more people
have to understand that so yeah there
you go Nick says based on what you've
seen this election cycle if DeSantis
gets the nomination who do you think
would be his best choice for the VP
position I think there's a couple
interesting options my gut feeling is
that he will not make
a traditional Choice meaning I don't
think he's going to be like okay now we
need the faux diversity so I have to
find a black woman or I have to find you
know as Douglas Murray said last week I
have to find an overweight
basketball player like I don't think
it's going to be like that
um I think there are some interesting
choices I think Kim Reynolds who's the
governor of Iowa I think she's a
firecracker that more people need to get
to know I've had her on the show met her
a couple times off camera like real I
just think she's great and fun and light
and she would just add like a little bit
of magic there that would be really nice
I think she would be interesting I think
if you wanted to do something really
kind of crazy you know he's going to the
right of trump that's a that's a
calculation that they're making in this
campaign but if you want to maybe for
the for the uh general election say a
little bit come back to Center or offer
the disaffected libs that group I'm
always talking about who can actually
move if you want to throw them a bone
maybe you bring in a Tulsi gabbard right
like that would be super interesting I
think there's you know there's probably
like a whole bunch bunch of other ways
you could go maybe this would be a
little more traditional thinking but you
could do a Nikki Haley or a Tim Scott
um I I don't know but I do think with
him at the top of the ticket the vision
will be very clear the vision will be
clear and as I often say it's like what
has this guy said he is going to do that
he has not done I don't know any other
politician in my life that's ever
operated like that so there's reason to
believe that he can make this thing
happen and that his promises aren't just
like these crazy over-the-top Notions
they're actually like granular things
that he can accomplish so I think if you
go with that and then he brings in
someone who's like my guess is
my guess is it's going to be a governor
because I think he likes people like
that I think he likes really functional
people and he likes people that have
governed so I don't think it will
probably probably won't be a senator
probably won't be a congressperson I
think he would go for another I'm going
Kim Reynolds that would be my guess uh
Lakers says the woke is more like a fog
in society and no specific group like
the Russian Bolsheviks so did the woke
grow out of the Democrat Party or did
they infect the Democrat Party it seems
like the latter as Obama warns of
circular firing squad and the classic
Marxist Bernie Sanders is always a step
behind the woke talking voice that's a
great question you're asking me sort of
chicken or the egg thing you know I've
talked about this a bunch in some ways I
don't think it matters I think the the
real answer to your question is that the
woke ideology which I agree it's this
amorphous thing it's like who's the
leader of this thing you know antifa
it's not a group it's an idea about all
these things
they used the soft underbelly of
liberalism right what unfortunately
deliberals generally put at the top of
their hierarchy of important if you have
a series of needs in your life you have
security you have family you have
you know in terms of where you want to
live you have weather location but you
have all these things that that have
some level of priority in your life
liberals generally for some reason have
put tolerance at the Apex of that that
you must be tolerant of everything and
this is uh Carl Popper's uh Paradox of
Tolerance you cannot be tolerant of
intolerance but the progressives saw
that within the Liberals and they used
that soft underbelly to use tolerance
against the tolerant people and that's
why liberals of today
seem like the most intolerant people
they've they've they've swarmed and they
have basically taken out all of the good
liberals so every time a decent liberal
comes around say me five years ago guys
this is not what liberalism is all about
I wrote a book about it you you guys are
not acting liberally what do they do
they push you out and then what you find
is oh you can talk to conservatives and
Libertarians and maybe we have a little
bit of different stuff here sure but
okay but we're all willing to agree to
disagree while the other side becomes
the hysterical authoritarians that AOC
is accusing everybody else of being so
they are the most illiberal in the name
of liberalism which is very sad because
the the liberal the idea of liberalism a
society based on individual rights and
rationality and laissez-faire economics
it really is what modern conservatism is
I would say for the most conservative of
you watching this you might have sort of
a religious notion attached to that
right god-given rights I'm personally
very okay with saying God given rights
the state did not give me rights your
rights are innate to you as a human
being as some would say God given for a
certain set of liberals they don't want
to attach that to to something Beyond
man I I'm personally okay with that but
I know that's one of the things that say
a Bill Maher might get hung up on if you
said they're god-given rights Bill Maher
would say well no they're not I don't
believe in God except that means that
the state it's either God or the state
right it's either it's either your human
Birthright that you are born by the very
nature of your existence as a free
entity in this universe and then the
state can come along and if it didn't
give you it didn't give you those rights
so what can this they do it can protect
them right the state can act as a
protector of what God gave you I'm
personally okay with with that as a
concept I know some liberals aren't
and I think that that causes again some
of the Divide on why maybe a guy like
Joe Rogan can't like fully get there or
Bill Maher can't fully get there but
these are these are very like small
nuanced things that I think we can work
through anyway uh Eva says hey Dave
what's your favorite quote from history
and why uh this one is very easy I
quoted on the show fairly often it is
Ronald Reagan the nine most terrifying
words in the English language are
I'm from the government and I'm here to
help I mean doesn't that sum it up does
that not sum it up after three years of
covid lunacy and masks and injections
and mandates and lockdowns and lies and
everything it was all pushed by the
government in in the name of helping you
and did they help you or did they
destroy your business or your family or
your psychological state of being or
whatever it might be it is not to say in
my opinion that the government has no
role in the world whatsoever it does
have a role it's what I just said to
protect those rights I'm not an
anarchist I'm not saying there should be
no government I'm not fully in Mad Max
yet I might be let's revisit this in you
know five six years but I'm not there
yet
um but the government is there to
protect your rights and when the
government comes knocking on your door
it is usually not because they are there
to help you Lloyd says what is your
comment on the mainstream media
continuing bias the alleged shooter the
alleged shooter and only then in the
last paragraph the alleged shooter was a
black male next story first line the
white shooter was armed and had ties to
right so this is what they do if it
doesn't fit the narrative right why is
it that Joy Reed will rail again about
how dangerous it is in Florida but would
never dare talk about the shootings in
Chicago
to me if people are shot unjustly if
there are murders I don't care about
their skin I don't care about the skin
color of who was shot or who the shooter
was Joy Reed does not want to report on
70 what was it 73 people being shot in
Chicago 11 being murdered because it was
all black on black crime she can't do
anything with that it doesn't help
her grand narrative her grand narrative
is white people are evil and they are
the oppressors and black people are the
oppressed so I will always go after
Florida
Florida the freest state in the nation
so this is the same thing with it
there's a trans shooter they don't want
you to know the shooter is trans if it's
a black shooter they don't want you to
know the shooter is black if it's a
white shooter with questionable motives
white supremacists right like this is
just how it works but again it's one of
those things just see it guys just see
it know it's and then hopefully
as time goes on you can wake more and
more people up to that fact Deborah says
what you and the family do on the 4th of
July well my folks were here uh it was
my mom's birthday so we we took her out
the two or three days before they were
here for the weekend extended weekend
and my sister came with her kids and
then on the fourth everybody had left
and it was it was just us and we
barbecued I made some wings I made
burgers and I made hot dogs uh grilled
some barbecue chicken and we took the
boys in the pool which they love getting
in the pool and the pool's here I don't
even have to heat the pool it's so hot
in Florida in the summer the pool's at
like 92. so it's like nice and
comfortable for them and and they kind
of do their thing and we just had like a
nice day just listen to some music I
made some Mojitos you guys know that I'm
a tequila Guy usually uh but went with
uh we did watermelona watermelon Mojitos
did a little muddling uh fresh
watermelon fresh mint a little rum quite
delicious uh Lawrence oh and then of
course fireworks at night which we
weren't setting off but they were going
off like crazy in Miami and Clyde was
having a freaking nervous breakdown we
gave him some of those common Treats but
he just plowed right through them uh and
it was a it was a loud evening to say
the least uh Lawrence says do you have
any thoughts uh to share about mayor
Francis Suarez running for president I
thought it was misinformation first but
there's a campaign donation page so
perhaps it's legit yeah he is running
for president I've mentioned him a bunch
I've had him on the show a couple times
I like him a lot I think he's a great
mayor I think he's done an incredible
job of taking refugees from all over the
country but largely from California from
Silicon Valley and bringing them here
and now Miami has such an unbelievable
uh an unbelievably strong economy we're
also voted the fittest city in the
United States the number one city to
work in the United States we have clean
roads you know we're building like crazy
there's a lot of traffic here because so
many new people have come we have an
issue with house prices because so many
people have come but these are these are
products of success we're also voted the
number one happiest city in the United
States and you can literally see it on
people's faces here when we go to the
farmer's market every Sunday like people
are happy and joyous they say hello it's
for me it's such a stark contrast
between the misery and depression and
Neurosis of Los Angeles
um anyway Suarez is running for
president my guess my it doesn't feel
like it's needed or sort of uh
I think he's doing it probably for
future political Ambitions we'll get him
on the show and talk about it for sure
he's already agreed to do it we'll
figure that out uh the question for him
right now is you know to get into that
first debate which is August 23rd you
need 40 000 individual donations I I
don't know that he's going to hit that
threshold there might be some other guys
that don't hit that threshold as well
but I don't know that he's going to hit
that threshold but you know a lot of
times it's just part of politics this is
not a this is not a judgment character
on anybody
um you know in politics you run once
knowing it you're just going to get a
little more a little more Buzz a few
more people to know about you and then
the next time is the one or the next
time or the next time or you keep going
right so it's not always about that
first 4am but yes he is running and he's
just a nice guy you know I mentioned a
couple months back we were having dinner
in Coconut Grove it's this nice really
nice sort of outdoor area like just tons
of people it's safe it's lovely it's
clean but I'm sitting there having uh
dinner at a sushi joint and Suarez is
just walking around saying hi to people
like he literally was just wandering
around saying house like that would
never happen in New York City where Eric
at first off he'd be booed right most of
the Mayors try to imagine a blue city
mayor walking around first that they'd
be shot or stabbed or assaulted or
whatever here he was just literally
wandering around tables just saying hi
to people how can I help uh yeah just a
good guy Amy says you mentioned that you
ate a hot dog on the fourth what kind
was it and what is your favorite hot dog
uh this July 4th we did the
old-fashioned Hebrew National which I
think are the go-to standard like grade
a hot dog right they they serve a higher
power right what do they say what's the
tagline for Hebrew National Hot Dogs We
cert we uh we answer to a higher
authority that's what they say I don't
know if they make do they have
commercials anymore or commercials on TV
still
um so they do great hot drugs if you
want to try another great dog that this
they ain't cheap and this is a premium
hot dog uh Snake River Farms does a
really fantastic hot dog it's like it's
for like four of them though it's like
it might be like 18 bucks like it but
but they're Primo big juicy dogs uh
Jazzy says Dave what did you what do you
think about the decision from a judge
that the Biden Administration cannot
contact social media Outlets to
collaborate misinformation well that's
what we covered on the show today I
would just add it's good it's really
good and thank God for the courts right
now where would we be without the courts
and that really is why what AOC is
saying pack the courts let's let's
investigate them it's so freaking
dangerous the courts have done a few
things here look sometimes the courts
will do something
maybe that I don't agree with right uh
but you have to you have to you either
believe in rule of law you believe in
the documents or or you don't now they
don't believe in the documents and they
don't believe in rule of law so she only
wants she's only happy with the courts
and Joe Biden is only happy with the
courts when the courts do what they want
but show me the argument I read actually
some of katanji brown Jackson Jackson's
descent there's no argument saying that
in any of these things I read the the
affirmative action one and I read the
the College admission one there's
nothing in The Descent saying oh this is
that the government does have the right
to just erase someone's debt like it's
just not in the Constitution they may
not like it but this is the problem with
progressives right even when they get
the highest level of power being a
Supreme Court Judge she's still trying
to put her ideology
into the court and thus on to the state
what Clarence Thomas what what John
Roberts what the other judges the more
conservative leading judges are they're
looking at the Constitution simply what
is in this document and by the way if
you don't like what's in this document
there are ways to amend it there are
ways to have more bills put in you need
Super majorities you got to get 67
Senators but like there's all sorts of
things that you can do that's the
legislative process the the progressives
don't like the legislative process AOC
doesn't like the separation of powers
she pretends to like them as she tries
to undermine them at every step of the
way
um but if you look again I think I made
the point clear if you look at these
three decisions there's nothing in the
Constitution that would force you as an
individual to do to use your artwork
your skills that would that the
government could force you to use that
those skills in a way that you don't
want that's the Colorado law there is
nothing in the Constitution that says
that colleges should be allowed to use
race as an admissions Factor right and
there's nothing in the Constitution that
says someone else should pay your debt
those are just like simple basic truths
they may not be happy with those truths
but they're truths nonetheless Elizabeth
says what is your biggest fear
oh
president AOC
um no I guess my biggest fear well
especially now like having kids like my
biggest fear is that the world that I
grew up in that I knew and that I know
we could have again that maybe we won't
get like that the things that I'm always
fighting for on this show
um that they don't come to fruition that
we continue that descent to hell that
that things get worse that collectivism
and socialism replace individualism and
capitalism like that Society somehow
crumbles that it will seem like a dream
that my you know my childhood a child of
the 80s and 90s that will all just seem
like a long lost dream that
um that it was really good and we didn't
do enough to defend it and then thus my
biggest fear would be that the world
that my children would be growing up in
won't be as good and I guess that's
incumbent on you as a as a parent well
as an adult to some degree but I think
very specifically as a parent to fight
for a better world and and most people I
guess don't they just check out it's
it's tough to do it's painful to do it's
uh
they're going to come get you if you do
but I just don't see a choice so I think
that's it that that the world would be
worse off for my kids uh ham-handed says
is there anything that will stick to
Hunter Biden uh he is more Teflon than
Bill Clinton I mean look they found
freaking cocaine at the White House and
then immediately the media's reporting
will never know who brought the cocaine
in it's like these people can face ID
every Grandma who is at January 6th and
somehow they they just announced we're
never going to figure it out I don't
know if it was Hunter Biden with the
cocaine there but the amount of stuff on
the laptop the barisma job the emails
the voicemails the crack smoking writing
off uh prostitutes like all of it and
the man's still freaking walks free I
don't know if though we'll ever get him
I do not know Democrat privilege man
I think this last question George says
whatever happened to all the January 6th
footage Tucker had what he showed
certainly did not sustain the deadly
Insurrection narrative you know I do not
know actually it's a great question
um McCarthy Kevin McCarthy did say he
didn't McCarthy say he was going to
release it wider than just Tucker do we
know if he ever did that
he as far as we know he has not done
that
I don't know uh maybe that had something
to do with Tucker being released if
Tucker's still sitting on the stuff my
guess is it will come out over time by
the way I just saw that Tucker is going
to be on uh Russell Brand's show on
Rumble tomorrow so that's fantastic and
maybe we can tie some knots a little bit
tighter with Tucker on the rumble front
you know that all depends on the fox
lawsuit and everything else uh so we
we'll see about that and get a little
info here Marjorie Taylor green said
that Congress should oh right right
which was an odd one Marjorie Taylor
green said the Congress shouldn't
release all of the January 6 footage so
it's it's all very confusing you got
Marjorie Taylor green somehow on the
side of AOC I'm on the side of
transparency on this one which is I want
to see more of the footage I want to
know how many feds were there I want to
see all of the video of them moving
barricades and letting people walk in
and the peaceful protesters and then the
rambunctious ones and and all of the
stuff you know the truth will set you
free ain't ain't it the truth
that is our program for today we have a
Friday Roundtable Extravaganza I'm
psyched for the show tomorrow we've got
Viva Frye and Robert Barnes Viva is on
fairly frequently every couple months I
haven't had barns on in probably a
couple years but these guys do a great
show Viva and Barnes they're over on
locals over on Rumble uh but both great
legal Minds both lawyers and they get
all the cultural stuff and uh Barnes is
a big Trump guy uh viva's probably
somewhere in the middle obviously I'm a
defense guy we'll get into all that and
more and we'll talk about the laws and
affirmative action and all that stuff so
stay tuned for that and if you want to
join us for the post game show give me
about 30 seconds at
reubenreport.locals.com and we leave you
with Teflon Hunter Biden
hold on I I need another hit or I'll
fall asleep
[Music]